he was born more than 18 months after
the war ended in Afghanistan
but two-month-old Muhammad Yasin is a
victim of the peace like other infants
in this Ward he's suffering from severe
malnutrition
Afghans are facing great economic
hardship the UN says this is the worst
humanitarian crisis in the world but
there's another problem here lack of
staff
we weren't allowed to film close-up
shots of the female nurses but they are
allowed to work as part of a medical
exemption from the Taliban the problem
is that both female and male medical
staff are leaving the country
with the situation of all these people
living here both nurses and doctors
these guys leave us here alone and as
well as living our nation there will be
a very bad effect as there are more and
more patients
this is one of the better equipped
hospitals in Afghanistan but Staffing
here is still a real problem there is
just one nurse here for eight children
the international standard is one nurse
caring for two children in an ICU like
this and the nurses here work 12-hour
shifts the international standard is
just eight hours at a time
One hospital in Kabul has had over 150
staff leave in two years although the
world health organizations say there are
no official figures for the whole of
Afghanistan being kept this is really a
very serious issue and as who we are
trying our best to be able to provide
that capacity building to those
healthcare workers who are left in the
country and many of them as in reality
when you say about this Exodus of
healthcare worker most of them are those
senior healthcare workers who were
already trained by the government and by
U.N agencies before the medical brain
drain comes on top of the withdrawal of
much of the international funding not
just for hospitals but for all
humanitarian projects Afghanistan's
Health sector faces a growing crisis
James Bay's Al Jazeera Kabul